yo are we live one and a two and a live
are we live reject Nation reject to
mundai you know what to do die let us
know if we are live John we're going to
do a thing in the beginning where we're
probably going to be sharing that Mouse
I don't do anything let us know if we
are live you know how we roll people
confused you know how we do let us know
if we live we haven't had a three of us
one in a while what do we got what do we
got it's three people in the morning
here to watch some what's going on Diego
eyes what's going on people Isabella re
all righty so we're going to get right
into it and explain why we are doing uh
trailer reactions live now this is kind
of experimental for us and when I say
kind of I mean a lot of last minute
scrambling and U mainly John figuring it
out and we are all very sleep deprived
we are going to have a good
time yeah and see
that's a good time that's a good time
now I feel it you earn you earned that
John so so guys thank you so much for
being here if you are here please go
ahead leave a like on the video we are
going to cover the trailer so right now
as we are live The House of the Dragon
trailer has not yet dropped but supposed
to drop sometime whilst we are live so
hopefully we hit that sweet time frame
where we can cover the boys cover
Fallout and then maybe by the time we
were done get some hot D we then we got
House of the Dragon out here on the
Chanel um yeah so Amazon and Prime video
and HBO they like when it comes to the
trailer coverage they never let us
monetize and so I was like I'm always
like spending forever editing it just to
get it unblocked and and then you know
you deal with these copyright claim
stuff like screw let's just do a live
stream and cover it live and just talk
with everyone here do in 2023 they know
that advertising is partly what we do
and they should let those live they
always eventually they always eventually
Let It Go the claim just so weird but
but by the time the views have stopped
like thanks it's just so weird it's not
a movie it's like the ad we're doing
your job so with that in mind Shameless
plug as always guaranteed to have your
question Read Super Chat and streamlabs
are welcome we never end a stream
without doing it and uh live streams are
are the playbacks on them are a little
bit tough and YouTube doesn't always
recommend them and they are often
demonetized cuz this one especially
likes to say something that gets us in
trouble but this one especially is going
to be demonetized because of what we're
going to feature in it so super chats
and all that very much welcome but guys
um I say uh thank you to so much who for
everyone who is here but we should just
start kicking this off right now and for
those in the playback there will be
video chapters let's get into it should
we just kick it off with uh the thing we
all know the most about the boys boys
boys boys
Bo do your thing man pull up the boys
all right it's time for the boys
everyone in the chat saying the boys I
they're talking about us or the boys we
are all yeah let's start with the boys
trailer season let's do this
thing hey look oh we're all big and and
and mighty all right so we're going to P
you be mindful of your leaning Coy yeah
forward or back or side just generally
let's just see what Ki has a habit let
me just block my I'm not going to have
control over the edit to help you here
and so all right that's your that's the
framing size we have to have a SL like
again we have to put an oval because we
just don't want it to get blocked for
sure it's not going to be monetized this
video but we there we go not blocked
that's a oh my God we saw homelander
spoiler I'm going to use this night swim
trailer really quick just to make sure
that y'all can hear I'm just going to
play a couple seconds let me know if
y'all can hear good old night
swim what we need a vacon
here
all right that's enough Universal
especially doesn't let us gets us in
trouble all right all right all if y'all
could hear that just we just need we
just need confirmation you were able to
hear that yeah yeah as long as you guys
heard that clippy that means you'll hear
this all right we're ready for the boys
it's time for the boys let's do it let's
watch the boys trailer all right ready
gang a one a two and a
three and a
three
and we're
off
Rome
Greece that's Amica all democracies
fail because people are [__]
stupid oh
yeah so excited to see them back but if
you crush the
masses who builds your
monuments
Tain oh he looks a little different yeah
the people will tear it apart
themselves you just got a nud on a
little keep America safe whoa Civil War
then you get to swoop in yellow's really
striking be the one saving it staright
oh he's enjoying like Caesar like
ceser how often do you think of ancient
Rome you always got a is that a new
black noar
je oh my God she's a vampire from Blade
black who wants their balls
[Music]
crushed
hair oh damn your team what's your code
name again the
boys who came up with that
[__]
ooh yeah yeah yeah got to update that
thumbnail the smile turning into Prime
the Cheshire Kat homelander file turning
into the Prime logo was so inspired that
was amazing Cheshire Prim Lander all
right well we can do something that we
normally don't do John like I said we're
going to hog the mouse let's just put
the trailer up here while they go okay
that was oh I see what you mean all
right we're going back we're going back
here we go and whoop yeah we yeah yeah
yeah all right so Coy if you want to
interact with the we can see the chat
okay I want everyone to know if I put
looks real good I it's not going to go
on top of that sadly it is an election
year what a perfect time for the boys
heill time all right cool so it's
goingon to look like that all right got
it yeah alrighty so go same let's go
through this a little bit here all right
Coy this is where you be get get to be a
master we're gonna break we're going to
go through the boys trailer bre Down
live bit by bit and then we're going to
and thank you for all who have already
contributed to the super chats and we we
will we promise to get to all them first
instinct a lot of uh beautiful
architecture in Roman inspired art as
they talk about the fall of Rome so for
boing and also showing Credence to him
being like Caesar and wanting to
be yeah yeah but I think looks pretty it
looks really pretty also it's the back
of someone's head implying him getting
shot like JFK it's
just now we're doing the real commentary
yeah guys please explain this VA video
Blockbuster love it's not
playing what it's not playing what do
you mean oh oh that's interesting I
don't know why that is it isn't I want
the I want the dialogue all right I want
to be able to hear what's going on all
right oh I'm G to just check
something we got a copyright cck did we
yeah it sh right
away oh that's good all right now you
can play it that's
hilarious
well golly you tell us when you want to
pause co uh pause here uh so they're in
VA video which is obviously a play on
Blockbuster Video but I'm curious if
this happens like in between uh some of
the stuff we saw in genv like I'm
curious if they tie in some of the
elements of him searching po right
that's I'm saying like so I'm wondering
if this is like the first episode like I
think this is going to be really early
on while he's hunting and I think this
this set I think ties in genv just a
theory sweet sauce P to say
he's going to remember them making love
back
there because people are [__] stupid
no I'm not I'm smart
smrt
cuties but if you crush the masses so
the Starlite costumes uh you know ju
deposed with the the other is really
interesting visually but I'm curious
what like causes this rallying behind
her like what does she do well she just
stands for like Liberty and well you saw
stands for like the moral side of thing
there's like a a woman's uh rights thing
that they were that was on some of their
signs so I'm curious if there's like a
speech or something at the top of the
season so stuff and things in the chat
saying this boy takes place one month
after genev that makes sense yeah that
makes a lot of sense so what's the Deep
going to do with this octopus he going
to do some some stuff I think uh we're
going to see more hint time we're going
to see a little bit more that's what I'm
talking about we see a little deep
there's a little deep in the corner
there's a little deep in cor a little
deep Corner little deep cor they're
definitely lovers cuz he's left a trib
himself in there all right good The
House of the Dragon 2 trailer is out
we're going to do Fallout after this and
we're going to do House of the Dragon 2
then we're just going to keep an open
Q&A
going Jitter Bean Coffee Cup M you know
what I like about this trailer normally
The Boys trailers are are they start off
with just so vibrant and fun and kind of
funky and so they leave with just
non-stop violence and the sexuality and
this one uh leans into the Menace of it
all this really has more of an ominous
flare which is normally not what I would
expect for your boy trailer so we have
Starlight supports women and then we
also have keep America safe that's the
sign I was trying to really I have no
idea what it's riffing on thank you to
all have been contributed we will we
promise to get to all the super chats
thank you so much what are all these red
hats they're really going to help out
the stream today especially already been
copyright claim yet I can't remember
where I've seen a red hat before it
seems so like friendly and welcoming
it's the Cincinnati Reds they're all the
Cincinnati Reds fans totally totally I
like how Starlight stuff looks like
Hamilton yes he does God bunch of
Broadway Kids
wow I like the slight Obama uh Starlight
face broad
Bama fight like a girl and well and the
and the raised fists together is yeah I
love this like she's horrified by the
outbreak and it's what he wanted well
that's that's what I love about the
prospect of this cuz so much of the boys
is is you know the joy and terror is
watching like oh man how unhinged is
homelander going to get in terms of his
life immediate power but I feel like one
thing that's smart at least about the
prospect of this is that they're raising
the stakes by going like oh the fall of
democracy like there's going to be
unrest Just Between the regular people
so instead of Simply worrying about
homelander coming around and massacring
you now you have like people being
radicalized like left and right also all
of this happening in broad daylight I
like how this trailer all takes place
outside in the daylight you see the the
Smashing of the person at the end like
this is soups just being everything that
the boys have feared they'd become who
is this uh we haven't met her yet does
anyone in the chat know who this
character
is we'll wait sound off people we're
wait I don't think we've met her I think
this is new we're waiting in the chat to
see if I I mean obviously she's a new
character but if she's someone from the
comics I wouldn't know from the dialogue
so far all right all right well someone
someone might who's holding hands with
ran bro that's Ryan's freaking Ryan
that's is not Ryan that shot isn't that
this is someone else's hand that's
someone in a trench coat that's a jump
cut to make us think it is that's also
on the wrong side of the that's a man's
suit it looks like a man's suit maybe or
unless it's uh what's her name unless
it's um could that be Marie's sister
some people are questioning if that girl
is Marie's sister um because she's a
black girl oh look out this this TR
bomb with what is what is her name the
uh oh I can't tell firecracker it looks
like so that looks like a you know Fox
News correspondent for sure woo dude
Jeffrey D Morgan for you guys who don't
know Eric kpy is the man who Helms
Supernatural and you know that is
obviously John Winchester this the
father of s and Dean Winchester he's
bringing everybody in yeah soon we'll
get Jerry pad lucky yeah season six boy
and for all you SN heads that's Thomas
Wayne out man H me a flk
it the Blade Two vampire the New Black
newr I'm very curious about him and I'm
curious if this is going to follow the
we won't do spoilers here but but there
is a think that would come around I
didn't think because of how three went
they could but now they really could
yeah now especially I'm like oh are they
actually going to really attempt to to
do that got to this looks distur looks
kind of like the effects yeah does
Starlight is so it's someone rebelling
against Starlight I'm sure here that's
like the thing I love it also I'm
wondering if gen V is
affecting my guy damn that ragy squeal
let out
man we will not spend as long on Fallout
or sorry Fallout I'm excited for
Fallout bro daylight team what's your
code name again the
boys who came up with that
[__] dude Carl Urban and Jeffrey deg
it's gonna be so great oh man wait it's
just crazy it's kind it's I kind of get
like that American Horror Story Vibes
flare because American Horror Story will
sometimes do that thing where they go uh
very topical with whatever whatever
their season is and I say topical like
what happened this year and with it
being election year next year and this
follow election year it's it's it's very
very top very pointed but damn this this
I have to update the thumbnail with this
image it's perfect let me just take a
little screenshot to update the
thumbnail why don't why don't we just
show the process on the screen guys you
guys want to see how it's done here all
right guys so we got to get to uh let's
uh John what super chats did we get
right now we we we'll we'll R them off
really quick inste back up and then we
will uh go to the Fallout trailer and
after Fallout and while you're doing
that John this is very experimental
stream I'm going to then we're making
art because I heard the house some
people in the chat said the house of the
Dragon trailer's out and some people are
saying it's not out but I'm going to
check really quick do we have hot D
sound off below also some people uh are
speculating that maybe black noir is in
a flashback but I think he's in the Pres
oh no I think he's in the Pres I think
he ties into the comic black nor I won't
say what it is oh co with his
Comics good for you I also think
Invincible episode 6 is going to have a
big Cameo I think it's out guys oh wow
so should we should we should we still
do this uh Super Chat yeah yeah let's do
it let's let's do the super chats really
quick all right let's go do some soups
let's do a couple all right here this is
the first one from raccoon shampoo thank
you for joining us raccoon I have live
10minute test thank you raccoon and I
have to go watch the new godzill I have
to I'm being forced to watch millus Oney
was the first one to tell me about it
and uh yeah my wife and I we are going
to go watch that because she's a huge
Godzilla fan oh she's going to be so we
got to talk imediately after the stream
got married last year and at this time
last year and I had to uh I got
hospitalized on the day of my wedding so
we are going to make up for it by going
to watch Godzilla thank raccoon shampoo
they're going to rush you to the
hospital during we're going to do this
once at a time let's go back to the
let's do the Fallout trailer once
raccoon is our one live stream I thought
we had like two super chats and I saw we
had a bunch and I was like you know what
let's uh we we're going to pick that up
later let's do we're going to do the
Fallout trailer right and then one more
Super
Chat then we'll do House of the dragon
and then it's just going to be an open
Q&A again this is going to be one of the
messiest live streams we've ever done
all right we are going back like it hit
that like sort of embracing it sort of
embracing we're back in Action you guys
ready don't hear so really quick before
we do this um do you guys know uh I I
don't know Fallout at all I know wton
Goggins I've played in Fallout it's been
a a minute but I played Fallout 3 a good
amount and uh you know and fallout
shelter it's a big open world game it's
a big game it's not like a linear plot
no I've never played fall no you explore
the Wasteland boy okay interesting yeah
you're you're as I recall part three
like you're searching for your dad or
whatever there is a plot but you can do
like three why don't you play one and
two first uh because Fallout it's one of
those games where like each generation
it gets rebooted like yeah you can
follow all the lore but like there's New
Vegas there are different each pocket of
the Wasteland that you're peering into
kind of has its own a generation in
terms of like oh we revamped the tech
and it looks better and all that stuff
but also I don't I don't think it's one
of those games you can be a completest
but it's not like oh you got to play
part one to understand part two you know
all right so chat are you guys excited
now I've never played Fallout are you
guys excited for this Fallout show we we
got to know if we're if we're going to
like it or not before we form our honest
opinion I'm actually excited to watch
something I have no yeah prior basis in
I just got to follow whatever people in
the chat are saying first they say hey
Christian unpronounceable always here
alrighty so uh yeah we have no I I don't
know anything about it um but let's see
what goes on all right let's try out
this is going to be for John who has
some familiarity and Coy and Greg who
have no familiarity yes I know Michael
tesler who's usually our Star Wars now
he's played all of Fallout he's a he's a
huge huge Fallout fan so I'm like do we
do that thing where where I bring him on
but I'm like but if he knows it too well
will he ruin the show anyway that kind
of watching it's a good game for being
like Oh iconography but it's not
necessarily the kind of game where
you're like I played it so I could spoil
the whole thing for you all let's check
it out let's see what's going on cool
here we go a one a two and a three
John it's not playing again all right it
doesn't seem to be working come on John
you know it's great about live you
didn't spend hours working on this last
night every time we live stream we
discover a new random ass problem one
two and a three hey it's play in the
vault 33 is a thing I
recognize I know that I've lived a
relatively comfortable Life The Vault
costumes
stop
Mercy oh it's her I like the
cinematography a lot so
far it's got some ABS in it step into
the
Wasteland oh Jonathan Nolan oh yeah
buddy to go home now I'm in okay Vault
dwellers are an endangered species yeah
that's a huge [__] you would be willing
to do what it takes to survive a p
classic tumble weed effect I love how
she was so dis by the T we nice if you
insist on
staying then you will have
to erson hello
Zep I'll give you that one Amazon I'll
give it to
you all right they got
jokes okay me they threw down for the
visual
effects that Terminator Salvation there
is a lot of different oh that awesome
like the armor oh
[__] yeah I like the ironic humor guy
that's that's definitely some Fallout
the humor yeah there's an
irony the ghl that's Walton go the ghoul
why does he look like Deadpool looks
there's a yeah we we'll talk about oh
shoot oh so it's like an apocal or
Western oh yeah can we cover this this
looks amazing The Moldy
one Cyclops Parell oh parns looks great
and Kyle girls this C is amazing oh
zombie bear wa cocaine Bear Went dark e
the fingers I have no idea what's
happening but I I love this so much uned
Walton goggin before yeah for the big
one oh my God is this La it's the Griff
Observatory the Griffith Observatory
right there
yeah yep did some of them take place in
in La hey rag where's the nuca kid yeah
I think there is yeah music's great
Jonathan Nolan means is gonna be written
like where's the nacac cola kid he he'll
show up who's the nuca kid he's actual
video game film souls in 2000 says in
the track yeah uh nacac colola it's it's
probably seen him he's the little happy
blonde guy with the thumbs up there's
definitely like an irony in this world
for sure that was a great trailer like
that was really good yeah you've seen
he's a little thumbs up boy oh
yeaha kid dude that was a solid trailer
I'm excited yeah let's bring it back
let's bring it back John you pay
attention to the chat all right guys
we're goingon to look at House of the
Dragon in a little bit that is that is
my reaction the whole time like I don't
know what's happening but I love it for
a variety of reasons um one I'm I I'm a
I was a big fan of the TV show Westworld
I've seen every season and Incredibly
disappointed that it was uh it didn't
get a finish it had one season left and
it didn't get a finish off the its
storyline and uh and I get a lot of that
flare here obviously I feel like there's
going to be some obvious things that
people Riff on or or see this and go hey
it kind of looks like this so yeah you
do got some stuff that kind of has that
Mad Max flare to it um but yeah a little
bit of West world meets Mad Max I love
the ironic sense of humor in here I
think the visual effects were really
solid what is Walton Gog is he like a
ghoul or something what's the ghoul yeah
uh basically there's like a a race of
basically once all the bombs go off and
stuff like that there are these people
who are like heavily
irradiated um who kind of take
on basically they look all you better
hurry it up joh they look all zombie
like and deformed like that and actually
some people are winging online because
he doesn't look as disgusting as they
have in the games this nose thing is
pretty [__] disturbing to me well
yeah but in you know they're more they
look more overtly like zombies and less
like Deadpool in the games uh but yeah
they're irradiated people who also I
think kind of absorb and can kind of
power up off of radiation uh now you
know post I also got Book of Eli
Vibes apocalyptic Western yeah
absolutely and uh and yeah there are big
creatures and and irradiated bugs and
stuff that are around and yeah you got
to go on all sorts of different quests
and side quests and stuff so who's our
main character is it the girl it's you
in the game I played you you create your
own character and then the game begins
with you being born in the vault I know
who's our main character in the show is
it this woman it's this woman yeah who's
this woman I don't know why is she so
terrified of this tumble weed I think
it's just movement like she's she's
never been in there she's like letting
the tumble weed pass as if she's going
through traffic she's like playing frog
I would let it pass who knows it's got
somewhere to go clearly it's on its way
somewhere interrupt the tumble I forget
what this actor's name is Michael
Emerson okay but for him to have to be
we will get to the house of the Dragon
trailer thank you guys for letting us
know yep um perfect timing we [__]
time the [__] out
of yeah Saturday chaos but for this
having that big like mystery what the
hell is going on better narrator for
exposition to come in and be like I'm
spooky over the fire yeah totally I love
the two shipping joke I just want to
give that a good credit again I I mean I
loved it for someone who does not know
Fallout this makes me want to now okay
chat I'm asking the chat right now
should I play the game like actually
play the game and then watch it or
should I just go in blind because part
of me just wants to go in blind so I
want to go in blind I'm enjoying not
being part of a fandom I like watching
something I love the symmetry of these
shots so much yeah I mean this looks
like a really fun show joyous it looks
like they had fun making this depravity
it looks like yeah exactly depravity is
a great word for like Bleak butun but
hilariously ironic like like really dark
like Nuka kid that seems like the tone
like I I only know that image yeah no
there's definitely like a humorous irony
because you're also living in a world
where people are used to this so there's
like the whole day-to-day mundanity of
being in the postapocalypse I also want
to see La as even more of what apoc grew
Vault doesn't know what a there's a lot
of emphasis on this tumble weed people
people are saying go and blind and I do
think it's one of those games where you
can do that because like if you play the
game you'll get the flavor for like what
the world is but it's not like oh I need
to refresh on some story or whatever so
like I feel like watching the show this
looks faithful enough that you should
get the gist all right John well okay so
now that we have done that we are let's
John Let's people are saying play
Fallout 4 Fallout 4 is the main one
recommended let's go let's read one more
Super Chat thank you guys who have
contributed to the super chats and uh I
don't know if we got any streamlabs but
this this stream is already demonetized
so so that's the only
way much a seg waiting happen appreciate
it but uh yeah if we can uh just read it
just read at least one let's do one
let's least one and then let's go to
House of the Dragon we'll go to House of
the Dragon can't wait I love that show
so much get some hot D get some hot D I
like that show Dragon hope you're
enjoying Godzilla minus one raccoon
shampoo oh and thank you for correcting
yourself less than 10 minutes till hope
it was a good time or is currently being
a good time Cody Bishop Greg why don't
you read that while I download this
trailer download the trailer we're going
to get the trailer for hether right
there in our
notifications um Cody Bishop is saying
hey guys much respect do you play video
games or what other Hobbies you all have
besides movies and TV shows and how long
have you been friends do you even game
bro well I've been uh after covering the
cut scenes for Spider-Man I have been
officially planning which is allowing me
to really go through like all the other
random levels and side missions and such
and like I have to play in weird chunks
so like just the other night it was 1:15
a.m. I said Google set a timer to 2 a.m.
so I could just P like I got 45 minutes
and I and I've been having to play it
like that and I finally got to black
suit Spider-Man after like a month and a
half I could only play in like 45 minute
chunks um sporadically yeah sporadically
it's very sporadic like schedule's like
all over the place so yeah but I I
wanted to actually get my my hands on it
and which has been really fun and and
they and yeah those cut scenes did live
out quite a bit of stuff actually I uh
I'm gonna be playing Miles Morales soon
because I don't have a PlayStation 5 so
I saved miles for my phone so I have not
played miles yet so my fomo is going to
be quenched with some Spider-Man and
then uh I play Need for Speed like I'm a
big race car game and I haven't played I
haven't touched a cons console
controller since Spider-Man Need for
Speed is the best video game I love
those so much uh but I haven't played
since Spider-Man so I'm going to play
that and then uh we've known each other
five six years have we I mean we didn't
really start like kicking like etal yeah
but like we we've like seen each other
in passing but we weren't like AC we
weren't friends you guys you guys were
sort of buddies and then way to
downgrade our lovey pretended to like
you he just wanted to get to me is what
he said no wonder I can never you on I
was like I can't talk to Greg without
joh he was always talking to John I was
always like oh yeah yeah should do
something together man GRE watching us
talk is Greg watching finally I found
somebody this over here he's working his
charm just side eye flirting I played
the long game and it worked it's okay we
got hot D I'm going to manage these
rejects just to get to Greg all right
guys all right guys let just keep
increasing them copyright claims let's
do it another hot d one two three oh
what short oh okay I'm sorry here we one
two one two three I I feel like it's not
allow
everything's got to fail the first take
is happening joh John remember remember
everyone's name John all right I
remember everyone's name here we go 1
two
three errors were made in the hours
following King vas's death King visera
Tor the wall
bef many will die oh my God I got
ni oh man and the Victor will eventually
Ascend the
throne God this looks
great let's
go there is no war so hateful to the
gods oh here we go there's a war between
Ken true that oh those dragons facing
off and no war so bloody as a war
between
dragons the anguish
[Music]
yeah rematch
yeah or not rematch Vengeance match not
rematch yo yeah she' be going after him
after what happened to her son right I
think that's what the commentary on the
dragons is about it's not actually about
dragons it's they they refer to
themselves as Dr play it again I want to
watch it again all right I want to see
in family fighting
it's like it's such a weird conversation
in my in my house because was my wife
has read the book yes and she's read all
Game of Thrones and I hav't read any of
it so I'm like this is all new for me I
don't know what's going on this is
fantastic I'm like other than I know
that some ties in a game Thrones these
blonde people relate ancient history
targaryan this is one where like I avoid
breakdowns for it and [__] because oh I
love the mystery of not knowing oh yeah
let's go let's go I want watch it again
the hottest thing but I do love the show
were hours following King maser's
death I'm a Dar the wall
be the scope of this show is always I
feel like they got this done so fast
yeah I feel like we just watched season
one yeah it's R there was a strike in
every every show taking come back they
were able to work past the another right
that's how it feels so fast everyone
else paused here everyone's thanking
their lucky
stars so hateful to the Gods is our
second time watching the TR for anyone
just tuning in by the way so we're
talking a little
more look at that this feels like so
much more ethereal this scope is so
enormous and no war so bloody as a war
between dragons what a way if this like
more mournful and sorrowful this time
yeah it almost feels like going from
Game of Thrones season 1 to season 2
yeah something I'm so excited
for like getting her revenge is this
scope cuz yeah the ending shot was just
on her right yeah after learning about
what happened to her son
yeah at least as I recall oh man that
was greatting but a just the tone of
that
alone oh man I could just watch this one
over and over again it's yeah it's a
great tease because it's got so much
mood but it also it seems like a kind of
trailer that is sprawling across a
season it's really only got one line
like the dialogue is one little
monologue which I love is just a little
bit of exposition well and it does feel
at least to me like that that feeling of
like okay you have like it was in Game
of Thrones season 1 like you've got all
these mounting stakes and tensions and
whatnot but things are still kind of
contained and then you get to this
ending point where it's like oh great
things are going to pop off now and yeah
look at this dragon with the W uh on the
uh I I don't know if these details were
in the dragon before is guys it looks
more I'm afraid to ask questions in the
chat right now because in the book each
one of these holes has specific
explanation that's from the third book
that's from the four B I'm honestly a
little afraid to look at the chat at
this moment hopefully you guys are cool
just tell us how hot you thought the D
was yeah oh yeah I know it's just like
there was so much loss in the last uh
season seriously it span so much time
and you're watching like lineage rise up
and and people who have like these real
personal vendettas while in the midst of
War I just and we had so much trauma
this is like you Vengeance I'm excited
to see all the rage come out yeah no it
feels like a real act two for a season
two you know well I mean the battles
like look at this shot god [__]
amazing shot that's a desktop way and on
your guys's Z because we had to crop it
in it looks even better you can't even
see the dragon don't even worry about it
look at that little edge of a shot there
you go there you go look at your new
phone background there's some dragons
gorgeous there's some dragons Oh What a
Beautiful that hot D I want to ride a
dragon oh dude this yeah this looks
feels like it feels like a
dream yeah that has it also has that
like especially for her it has to be and
I noticed there wasn't they surprisingly
did not lean into Damon yeah I I figured
it' be very Matt Smith heavy or anime
super villain guy heavy but instead it's
just touch oh what is his name he's such
a great character Aon I think yeah he's
so fun to watch well that's the thing is
that this feels like um whereas the
first season is very focused it feels
like this is going to broaden out the
board and be like okay now everyone in
the realm is sort of responding to this
and there's like yeah going to be huge
disputes over lineage and power and and
you know who gets to rule and blah blah
blah I love how Matt Smith just gets to
be so like pensive and like
authoritarian yeah I love this character
for him so much all right guys let's
pull up the chat dude that was some hot
D thank you we got let's readjust here
okay oh goodbye legs goodbye the chat
we're going to readjust the framing and
all that all righty let's do that
thing in a world of pure trailer
reactions we're gonna demonetize for
John's song he's gonna copyright shal
shalam La all right hey we're back heyy
hey am the chat not a John amond amond
Aon amen amen my bad thank you thank you
there you go figh of we already covered
Fallout you're late you're late Dei Just
Tab backwards this is one of those shows
where every episode Hot D I got to like
relearn everyone's don't worry guys
we're hey Michelle uh we're already
going to be covering um we're already
going to be covering uh Reacher season
two so
excited going to be doing a trailer
reaction for Reacher where it's coming
out shortly I watch Reacher one yet
dude I hate you let's catch up on some
supers uh thank you guys so much who
have contributed to the supers because
uh yeah stream very much demonetized yep
is there any other trailer we should
watch uh from another major Studio to
demonetize well just like should they
fight the copyright claim Gozilla versus
Kong is tomorrow oh so we'll be covering
that yeah that's exciting all right what
do we got here in the all right I'm
about to go see the new a24 movie with
Nick Cage I've heard that as good dream
are you seeing Godzilla minus one first
or after have you seen that clip of uh
after what are you seeing both are you
doing like a double feature for what
Godzilla and dream scenario I was asking
you said
youill oh you reading I was like I
thought you were talking about your day
hey Charlie Fernandez good to see you in
the chat poo Pride dreaman Zilla can you
refresh it I'm not going to refresh it
ever I don't refresh stuff you refresh
stuff you're
fresh MK1 is dropping a new gameplay
soon I am always
is that game out we we've come this yeah
but they usually do like add-ons and
stuff yeah DLC koi come on downloadable
Co tent yeah every knows I know games
there's so many trailers this morning
did did we do Cody Bishop hey guys thank
you so much for being here you know
honestly like it's so it could be
stressful like when you're in a rush to
assemble the this morning was chaos like
putting them together and all that stuff
it could be a little bit I mean putting
the stream together enough was was
already like a little bit hectic and you
know just the idea of like doing like
three trailer videos stack to stack to
we got Dr Who coming out more efficient
oh yeah there's so much happening today
and so to uh but this is this is super
experimental for us on such a big
trailer day and I want to thank everyone
who's here uh and I I think this was
really fun all the chaos that led into
being able to pull this off honestly
it's actually been a lot of fun so thank
you guys for being here absolutely Super
Chat we're not we're not used to this
side of it whereas like I know other
people are a little bit more more better
acquainted at doing the live [__] than
we are so we're
trying you guys all right did we do Cody
Bishop we we did we are at Matt of all
trades thank you so much Matt of all
trades good name love being a part of
this live stream we love having you you
three are the Dream Team K keep kicking
ass guys thank you so much thank you
apprciate the love M you keep kicking
ass you got a good icon
there the Jack of all complim A's always
in our stream so in case you guys don't
know we just covered the three trailers
uh for that we that are in the title we
have honored the title yes the boys
fallout hot D yeah now we are just doing
an open Q&A for it but if you guys are
just tuning in you guys can go back and
watch it uh if you'd like we'll be here
we'll be here we'll be waiting roads of
teal thank you for being here we
appreciate you watched Godzilla minus
one yesterday great movie hope you watch
it I am vowing today to never watch
another Godzilla ever again out because
of how good they are shin Godzilla
that's enough for me uh well yeah I mean
you we have a deal going oh my God what
a generous Super Chat you see that it's
a big stress relief now we can pay now
it
is okay now we're good we're good now we
can
relax all because spread my legs out
there it is we get to manspread now man
spread baby we earned it we get to man's
friend now now we do I was crossing it
we be adults and proper before uh
Godzilla minus one is one of my top of
the year um I was lucky enough to host
the O Premiere but what was cool was
before the premiere I had to see the
film direct questions to ask the the
gentleman who made the film and uh I
watched it at um like a private
screening in this giant circular room
where they were mastering the atmos
sound so I watched the film like by
itself with no one and uh I got to hear
the sound master
and then I got to watch it with an
audience and like see how they em
reacted to it it was really it was a
really special experience and the film
is one of my favorites ever and probably
is my favorite monster movie of all
time can you guys hear John and I how'd
you do that John oh was right there that
you just got to highlight the one I
didn't know that's what I was trying to
find out like which button is it guys yo
can't wait to get to you there buddy
this is how the sausage is made yep
you're seeing it now I tried to Vamp As
Long John and I were like let's let's
try not let's try not to let the the
audience here joh and I like I don't
know just you saying I I can't hear you
this is like a football like where they
pick up a microphone from this was a bad
IDE maybe we should just say it into the
chat there it is I have a I have a fun
game you can hear them in the pit crew I
have a fun game for how to read these
though so yeah we we have um like here
at the channel like obviously we do
movie reactions here um a lot more now
so we kind of have we kind of have to
pick and choose sometimes like all right
who's going to get to watch us in the
theaters and who's going to be able to
watch us here so and I know like there's
channels like blind wave for example
where they seem like they never go to
the theaters uh sometimes they do but
more often than not it seems like they
just wait and but here we're kind of we
usually just only keep three people on
camera at most but we and so it's a
little bit of a pick and choose game and
because you and Andrew covered Shin
Godzilla I get to go to the theaters to
watch Godzilla minus
one covered no fair now I'm excited to
cover with Andrew I'm looking forward to
that react there will be a
mayi get ready all right now read it
whoa May R of do it
John all right all right fine demon
laughing my run
nari when is Godzilla XCOM trailer
releasing tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow
it's coming out tomorrow at
130ish I think is their panel so look
out for what else is tomorrow it's
Sunday the the Lord worshiping the Lord
is day of rest day of rest our Doctor
Who reaction goes up going to debate
with half the audience about our opinion
on about when Doctor Who got woke yeah
just point on the timeline when this out
yeah I agree with you River Rock the
show that welcomes
people on hi
Tamil oh there it is quiet
there I try to act like now now I'm just
so um unfazed by how how chaotic you can
send this to sponsors and be like we're
a well yeah we know what we're doing
guys professionals look like check out
this live chat here here let's Weir are
the definition of throwing spaghetti at
the wall see what all right we're going
to want to see more that's a great
question first watching this live stream
we're going to read Ana's uh one right
now here we go
uh hi wanted to stop by and say miss and
love
y'all that's for you you get the cookie
V felt it Ana we love you very much
shouts out to you in TAS I get what the
problem because normally it's just the
two of us it's just two at a time so so
fitting all three of us
on making yeah the ratio is a little bit
odd yeah okay I was like why does this
look
weird
that makes sense this is in a special
format now it's letter box yeah all
right yeah uh you know we should just
have like super bright visuals
constantly changing in the background
here's what I'll do I mean we could put
a video in the background [__] what if
we just play something back to who
there's just Mt Matt has joined us there
you go now they're just going to exist
underneath
us there we go here well there we go
kind NE that's fine I love how people
will come and be like hey jabby did this
so you should do it jaab I don't do
anything jaby your brother does it you
have to no this is how it works Morgan
Han thank you I love you too thank you
Morgan Han for being here I
miss love y' that's for you robot so
intense uh we missed theow down
sometimes too I miss it I did I pitched
uh I told um I I told Christian I was on
their the the his pod his patreon show
yesterday or two days ago and Christian
wait when was Monday today Saturday
today is Saturday oh my God it was not
yesterday that you did days ago
yesterday Monday so I was I was on um
and I told him like you know a long time
ago I had a movie idea for the Schmo
down to do like a YouTube movie like it
would just be on YouTube and and I'll
tell it here right now I'll try to make
it I'll try to pitch it in one minute so
the idea was that like uh we were going
to John and I were going to go do a
match and then I complimented
Christian's wife about how hot she is
and then he actually didn't take too
kind to it so then he sets me up for
failure during the match we're fighting
against Jay Washington and he's like so
in jeno and chain what is the most used
word that CA controversy and I was like
uh say it yeah and he's like but you
have to say the actual word or else you
don't get the point this what they're
saying you get the actual word I'm like
I can't say it
you going to fail the match and then I
say then I just get cancell but then I
wake up and it's the same day again and
so then I'm living a Time Loop for
theog day Brown Hog's day but like an
nword Loop of cancellation yeah it'll be
fun uh don't worry we're not going to
cover this we look we went in totally
blind for Reacher season 1 so we are
actively going to avoid reer season
we're going Blinder we're going to wear
blindfold watching re Reacher season 2
comes out in uh just in a little bit a
little bit later so uh we're going to
like next week or two weeks from now and
they're going to be preparing three
episodes so we're just going to wait uh
for that to come out uh but yeah we will
we're definitely be covering the Fallout
show th% I'm so looks great fasty
says Greg should be white I like to yes
beautiful beautiful work on that Greg
you haven't you been told that I am half
white yeah but you more whiter Italian
counts as as white fasty says more white
yeah yeah you should be all the way uh I
covered the last herb under
trailer I hate when people request stuff
that we've already done use the search
bar I get mad I'm pissed damn it John
I'm not good at choosing the butt that
was a good one that is this is this a
different menu
yes yes leave a message now whenever Coy
wants to see the c word now I can hit
that this [__] person in the chat is
such a think that they and
then hell yeah that's I'm talking about
people if you guys are just here uh
please uh leave a like on this video
thank you to all be contributing here
and uh the streams and the supers John
yeah do me a solid what you what do we
do can you check uh to see if there's
anything in the Stream I don't check the
super uh stream yeah I don't check stuff
uh Roy 2192 moment of silence thank you
my friend what is this button do John
talk oh goodness it's the large robot
function I am a large robot I am a large
human he really mess with your brain I
really enjoyed that I can I can program
this later to have both of you on there
I just have to do it from the computer
like all right here we go here we go
Deadshot thank you for the super he's
saying Noir might be Sam from gen V
that's my theory a month later and it's
him yeah uh Sam's pretty
small
that is they can augment his body I was
like here we go they can augment his
body we got we got a COI time we can
take it easy while Koy does a rift Sam
small move it it's not possible move it
along no else world no no speculation
for me it's pretty small Prett small
girl he's 5'4 doesn't work doesn't track
does track at least a 62 black noir man
I don't buy it uh I it's a fun Theory
because I do think they're going to be
in the show but I don't think it's going
to be I think it's going to be the comic
book story line of Blackmore which is
very different than the way the show
went P one which I also while while
we're ranting or while that was the
pitch for me to rant uh is I do think
it's really smart of the boys to steer
away from that comic story line and then
potentially steer back to it it's a very
inventive way to make us comic fans
happy got we got one we got one oh my
God what we got one oh my God we got a
humongo one we got a hunka hunka hunka
hka Super Chat yeah what do we got it's
our boy it's The Boy The Boy hold on
uh what's going on I'm making the screen
symmetrical again oh okay not leaving a
black but see the nice thing is you can
just keep want to get this limited ads
on a video that's already demed can they
take away more the beautiful thing about
the a bill is that you can keep talking
and it will just cut the audio so like
yeah that's funny
yeah though see I know okay all right
rard 2192 Jensen Carl and Jeffrey need
them in season 4 dude yeah that is kind
of the um the hope that people have you
seen
Supernatural That's A Dope Show man yeah
that's a great show I love kpy now so I
I would love to see how he started
usually the favorite show that we cover
at patreon because we don't um we don't
we we uh we're like season 13 wow and we
still like really look forward even when
after like experiencing really bad
episodes we still like extremely look
forward to it's that show that you love
no matter the highs or the lows hell
yeah I love that show so much and like
those guys are so Charming like a Tik
Tok of them comes across I always watch
it it's what's really impr what's really
cool about it is you know normally by
that point actors are just kind of just
showing up on set right and they're just
and Jensen and and uhar Jared Jensen and
Jared they they show they they're there
to like constantly improve and it's
really cool like they they really show
up such good things they they've truly
Amalgamated their experiences over time
you think that they would just kind of
get lazy and get their check but no they
and they do cons every weekend between
filming like they were they get stronger
as performers every season it's kind of
nuts J knackles is always like I'm not
I'm trying to bring it back always got
the Winchesters and after Winchesters we
going try and bring back Supernatural
again I'm like whoa dude somebody in the
chat just real quick uh let's give a
little round of applause SS2 for your
third live stream super all right John
let's check it out all right here we go
we do got to make sure we end at a c we
do not finish the stream without doing
all the supers and such uh and the
streamlabs however um we do got to make
sure we end by a certain point because
we got Doctor Who that we got to cover
doct man and uh we going to be a very
extended day that's right but thank you
guys for being here this is this was I
think this this is really fun
roasted it's not fun when you put
together like you spend like okay it was
going to be a few hours putting all this
together and then just keep like
blocking her copyright C or you have a
chat like we had three weeks ago or
whatever when we so this is this is way
more I I think this is way more fun yeah
yeah thank you guys this this has been a
blast roasted you guys think butcher
will have to take real compound V to
save his life Coy make your time worth
it uh I think they're going to be uh
dealing with the ramification
of the drug like the the oxycodone
hydrocodone methodone version of
compound V in the beginning and I think
by the end there's going to be a
commentary on like what you have to do
to fight soups like fighting fire with
fire so I do think at least a couple of
the boys will end up being uh
permanently on compound V by the end and
I do think we're getting like a season
five where it's going to be the big
battle of power powered up folks uh so I
do think a a baseline of compound V for
at least butcher maybe more than boys
that's what I'm talking about on St boys
St boys okay so let's uh the live chat
would be here sure there it is hey so
whenever we're talking about a certain
subject we slide that over we'll slide
the image over move the clage over all
right I like it all right J blazing
moment of
silence oh thanks for watching the
hairspray video we I really have you
seen herb uh the Zack Efron movie yeah I
saw it in theaters yeah uh so I watched
it with Aaron yeah uh Alexander fun and
we did not we had no idea about it we
were joking in the intro we were like
hey we don't uh like we don't know
anything about it I know normally you
might expect me to like pair with one of
the girls on the channel cuz it's
musical but they've all seen it so I'm
here with Aon my my big tall black
friend here we were like joking about it
because we thought that it was uh it
would not be in any way black
mood whole intro with the commentary
sudden this starts coming over like I
had no idea I did not choose you I'm so
sorry this wasn't because you're black
that I chose this
movie The
Story it is oh that's amazing we just
watching it going this is oh I love that
so fun we had no clue it was so oh my
friend n just played uh the lead in the
hairspray on Broadway here in
La koi knows someone SE KO knows people
oh my God you just dropped a name let me
pick that up for you I said my friend n
didn't say a name drop just a friend of
mine who played the leaded hairspray
they're a name drop button want to press
we got to have we got to add a little
name got a coin somebody well I'm just
saying it was cool to see the
reinterpretation on Broadway after
seeing the movie in high school on the
big screen every time you do that now
it's going to be time for
a so uh just ready Jess blazing J
blazing uh maybe we'll cover the Grand
Theft Auto 6 let you know J blazing
moment of silence thank you so much J
blaz appreciate you Luis Santos is so as
well thank you for the momento
deeno apparently blocked one of our
followers which I probably enjoyed
Marvin shouldn't have done that that's
that's a suvenir for you it's an honor
to be I'm trying to get blocked by koi
right now B books B books you're so
close John new images for Godzilla
multiplied by Kong have been released
how do you do that monster math anyway
you know I want to see Godzilla and
Kong's Offspring okay I appreciate the
Super Chat I appreciate the Super Chat
immensely I don't uh and because you
super chat I I'm like oh we should look
at it at the same time the trailer comes
out tomorrow and I feel like the less we
see the more rewarding the trailer
reaction will be don't I want to
diminish my returns at all that's how
you can tell if it's good is if you look
at all the stuff and it still works you
you got to see every single frame then
watch the movie you want to know a
little thing that uh a few a lot of us
can tell when a when a reactor has
already seen oh my God it's so obvious
there's a couple people think yeah they
don't want to seem like they researched
in smart beforehand some sometimes I'm
like I saw you Tweeting that you saw
this at at some an hour later at some
events that you were at and now you're
that's a totally different social
network this is the first time you've
seen this like just saw you like on
Twitter yeah it is pretty obvious
randoom Mando something it's funny thank
you for the first time every single live
stream they were like do you read
regular chat sometimes and I'm like yeah
we were clearly using it for the
narrative every every stream someone
says that when we always clearly
interacting he did the Monster Math are
you guys serious smash it was a
graveyard smash uh GTA was the first
play She Grand Theft Auto 3 was the
first PlayStation uh 2 game I ever
played and but I I haven't played since
San Andreas actually so I played that
City San Andreas and the I just haven't
picked it up again I was really into the
N the one where you're the Russian guy
yeah I had enough exposure Grand aut and
L I used didn't really enjoy went
outside life just you just went outside
your door and your and your stars went
up cop cop car and helicopters show up
out of nowhere you like all this this is
life o a background yeah okay it all
right okay lana. org Lana my dear Lana
our beautiful friend Lana just saying hi
love and appreciate you guys thank you
Lana so much we appreciate you hope she
owns that website lana. yeah I hope so
too all Lana L's really sweet she's been
in so many of our she she's constantly
here in her Liv she's such like for
Years Years thank you so much I don't
even stay invested in things for
years minutes I haven't played GTA V
very serious about played five I've
never play new Tekken game what's up I
would love to watch Chucky season on my
own time all right Christian
unpronouncable uh Christian
unpronouncable again one of our top top
contributors always here in our than so
much and we can pronounce you every time
have any one of you guys watch Stanley's
lucky man uh no have you I you know what
that is it's about a superhero who
always gets lucky in the bedroom or life
only in the bed it's his x-rated I
actually did have a story idea about
there might be good luck Chuck like you
know how there's Domino oh yeah we got
another first timer
Diego so Domino but yeah but the luck is
just sexually hold on I'm learning how
to I I have decided in this moment I
must accept that we all interrupt each
other like crazy that's you're just now
aced we've been doing this for two
years and I'm trying to just like Focus
here here weird time for that light bul
other we'll we'll mute the other mics
until you're done no no no no yes two
years in what we talking about oh luckyy
but about how uh there's no reward when
you're always winning right you know
like and I think that there's got to be
some weird type of existential conflict
that can occur I'd love movie about that
or a black cat movie would' be really
interesting like other people getting
bad luck so she always wins and how that
like eventually gets old because if
you've got that lead up do you even feel
like you're winning yeah duh winning
that's that's in my commentary that's
what I got mad at everyone for
interrupting
me all right we need another refresh we
do but we got to look at this okay we
guys we let's John
please Zoom it in all right Zoom it in
whoa no that's November 22 already
zoomed in okay cooln refresh it refresh
it Jes got refresh it's December right
it's all the time all right here
we oh
oh you're on November
John I was doing that for dramatic
effect G whoa look at this guy November
I want to show you guys just how insane
Chris of a like I talk with Chris Wham
off uh so and the guy's recently engaged
congratulations and I won't be I won't
get um to specific here out of respect
however as a man who has panoy Pride he
is marrying a
Filipino that's what I'm talking about
man you are my mom and
dad
yes I am so excited man that
flabbergasting number just whams me
right off I'm so excited for you dude so
excited for you play that is a um dude
Chris swam off look at this guys he has
been incredibly gener because he knows
that there was a lot of I like how he
says no show it we're gonna show it
there's been there's been a lot of
there's been a lot of different things
that have occurred behind the scenes
here and Chris has been very especially
during the strike season and Chris has
been extremely helpful and generous so
thank you
Chris he's already been a very insanely
kind gentleman but like he already
contributed like a couple of times this
amount and now heting this amount again
and soon he's going to have no money for
the wedding no I was hope for his you're
going to have to be the minister we are
going to have to bring the Rings up and
can I The Flower Boy you the yeah I'll
be the ring
guy if you invite us we will go I'm just
letting you know yeah no we're there oh
we're we're definitely there that would
be really fun actually I think he's in
Michigan yeah oh let's go to
Detroit always want to go to Detroit
let's do a live show in Detroit let's do
a live show in Detroit Chris is asking
hey are you guys going to do anything
for Godzilla minus one well John and
Andrew because uh they're prior
commitment and they're going to react to
it I'm going to go enjoy it with my wife
I have a review up in my channel and wow
yeah this time last year was at a
wedding and my wedding and uh end up
getting you were just at it Greg ended
up getting hospitalized were you at the
wedding yeah but I but I had to leave
the wedding cuz uh some catering person
[__] you want to know a funny behind
the scenes story real reject uh I was
supposed to be at the wedding and I got
uh a really okay so I got I went to a
con and I caught this thing called RSV
which is usually only for kids but I had
really that's what it turned out to be I
had really bad covid the year before so
my immune system was tanked so I went to
this Con end up getting RSV but it it
turned into um a head trauma that almost
turned into menitis so basically uh
Greg's wedding was like so important to
me and I had gotten my plane tickets
John and I were trying to figure out the
moves and I was really sick for weeks
leading up to the wedding but I was like
I'm gonna go and so I go to the doctor
right before to get cleared like
literally the day of I'm sending Greg
pictures of me at the doctor and I'm
like okay they just said if I fly 70%
chance of facial paralysis 80% chance of
hearing loss cuz basically my head was
so clogged if I had descended in the
plane it could have ruptured my eard
drum causing facial paralysis and I was
like should I come do you that seems
like a thing that is dangerous and so
like the next day I'm like Greg I'm so
sorry and I couldn't get in touch with
Greg it's his wedding I don't expect to
get in touch with Greg but then the
following day he's like hey man I'm in
the hospital and I was like what like we
were avoiding all hospitalization by me
not coming to this wedding and so I find
out after me being in and out of doctors
and hospitals that Greg uh has been uh
poison at his own wedding and it was
very dark last year this time and and so
I'm going to go enjoy one of the rare
occasions where I'm going to go enjoy a
movie in the theaters and I'm not going
to feel pressured to uh make a video
about it a I will give my opinion
casually and periodically on it I'm sure
in a future stream it's exceptional and
I'm glad everybody's love and as much as
I know like yeah it'll get views just
it's good to see you'll catch my opinion
I'm I want to just watch a movie with my
wife do that what yeah Aisha Kenya a
live show in Texas would be so dope if
we could collab with Double Toasted all
righty I thought I to go to Austin for
like more than a more than a day uh
Chris Chris whof is also saying LOL
looks like I wasn't the only one excited
about GZ1 minus one Godzilla minus one
is exceptional I have heard some amaz
like some fascinating feedback favorite
monster movie of all time I'm so excited
I've heard that man I've heard that
people love this [__] people are like
this is like everything I wanted from a
monster movie but also like this is
Oscar so when I saw it I saw it like I
said in a void by myself and because I
had to screen it before the premiere and
then at the premiere I was so curious
how the audience would react and I had
the cool thing where at the end I got to
sit on the stage waiting for the movie
to end to do the Q&A and I got to watch
the audience watch the movie and it was
so beautiful to see people laughing at
the same time and crying and it was uh
like two3 American one3 Japanese
audience and it was so cool to see this
big big emotion and then like other
people getting comfortable giving big
emotion and like the shared cultural
conscious it was beautiful man I love
that movie so much all for you Chris
Wham
off my sexy sexy friend all John refesh
I'll be looking here hey Bucky Chris
Bucky Barnes in the chat of course thank
you for being want live show
too everybody gets a live show everybody
is Doctor Who already out uh uh I
thought it was out thought was 11:30 I
thought it was out Christmas no matter
started airing oh there's a Christmas
special yeah there is a Christmas okay
that's what I I thought you were talking
about yeah all righty let's say let's
all
righty see next X going show up in we
got this one right yeah we did these
moments we're way there we're way we're
way we're way down John right there John
so far down right there there Black
Phillip philli plus raising their
subscription price so you don't share
passwords we get Winterfell thank you
though for being here we get Winterfell
and the Starks in season 2 surprise do
we really damn we get the Starks coming
to season two exting I'm glad they
waited on that that's usually what the
sophomore seasons do with these shows
huh they add in more that's when they go
like all right now let's get you some
things you really the H gave you just
this one thing and now we're going to
spray all the stuff you Rec sequel
sequel we got to let you realize that'll
probably come into the what have I done
this time oh sorry the Hot D we're back
keep track of everything all the variabl
learning slow we can't help each other
out never my job singular I got to put
the stream I'm putting the stream on my
back all right so leave a like for me um
but yeah oh man I can't wait for that
dude and they're all going to be played
by Shawn Bean everyone all the living
ones he won't die anymore and we'll be
like yeah there are hundreds of years
until he's supposed to die so like at
least he's got plot armor that's true
dies every EP damn it Sean I want to
make a they like people make meta things
about Nick Cage I want to make a meta
sha Bean movie about him constantly
dying can we make a sha Bean movie where
he's the only Immortal the actor will
live past all of us and that's why he
dies in movies yeah he's so comfortable
dying he lives
forever guys guys we got an insanely
kind super generous Super Chat here
stupid swi thank you stupid sandwich so
much hey everyone massive shout out to
Greg Coy and John along with the rest of
the reject Nation uh thank you for so
shout out to you stupid sandwich and
thank you to everyone who's been
embracing as we've been expanding thanks
John for doing that sorry thank you to
everyone who's been embracing uh the
expansion of the amount of hosts that we
have here on the channel it's been uh it
helps out for us to have a more variety
and at the same time uh you know it's
not easy introducing a bunch of people
on as regulars and I think everyone's
been just very very kind and welcoming
uh I just wanted to use this soap box to
encourage everyone to see Godzilla minus
one M it is so cool you know I know
Godzilla is like it's such a massive
franchise at the end of the day it is an
international movie and to see how it is
taking off so much here in the states
and now people are like it's a must see
in the theaters and like Godzilla is so
popular out here already but for it to
be one from Japan that everyone you must
see this in the theaters and you're
seeing just the amount of support around
it is making me Chomp at the bed I can't
wait for you to watch it on the TV John
hly the best movie I have seen theater
since Enemy at the gates haven't seen
Enemy at the gates I haven't either this
this is Sniper movie I haven't seen the
one with Jude Law I think it's the
moment with you like let's all react to
Enemy at the gates together that's what
we're doing here on the stream guys guys
let's throw it onemy at the gates it has
gotten to the point I mean like I will
want to see Godzilla minus one in the
theater at some point in my life but
like we live in a place where that's
possible and we've gotten to a point now
where I'm no longer like bummed to save
these things for reactions depending
like sawx is like one of the movies been
looking forward to so much this year but
I was also like I'm excited to do fun to
share I'm excited to share that on
screen so like so yeah Godzilla minus
one I'm I'm cool that's good I'm I
cannot wait and and that's the thing is
like I love that the American Godzilla
iterations especially with the monster
verse are very popular but I love that
like it's a shared property now and even
Shin Godzilla seemed to be like kind of
commenting on directly on that but I
love that Japan like the you know the OG
Godzilla or you know uh Pro progenitors
yeah uh like can always come in with a
showstopper and like the entire world
gathers around it and and I love that so
all righty guys beautiful beautiful now
normally we we don't end the stream
without reading all the super chats but
we have to like just because we got to
stay on schedule today for such a crazy
schedule uh John we should probably
close them let's no we're going to do is
we're we're going to finish we are going
to read everyone that's already come in
um but yeah we should be able to we have
to stop from allowing we're only
allowing stickers at this moment because
yeah we just want to make sure we end
Tamil Godzilla minus one is my favorite
Godzilla movie Shin Godzilla is my
second Godzilla 1954 is my third uh and
then 199 and then Godzilla uh king of
the monsters is my fourth Cody really
yeah I like K the monsters quite a bit
got a still track guys Okay C Bishop you
guys watch other react three people just
just under the wire go you got your just
under the wire to get it right before
John uh candit Cody Bishop do you guys
watch other react channels or YouTubers
uh yeah CO's Coy only watches nerd roic
videos yeah I go to sleep that's why I
wake up happy to get on Twitter uh Cody
Bishop yeah man I mean uh God I gotta
just I mean the my obvious go-to ones Mr
Sunday movies uh Double
Toasted um
joh Chris
Duckman I watch the lawyer I do watch I
do watch legal eagle legal eagle that's
the one watch myne um I love Cosa
variety hour I I like YMS and God red
letter media red letter media yeah
there's a great hi top films 3C films
spoilers C wonders screen Crush Double
Toasted um God there's a lot of people
Patrick H Williams is great one Patrick
H Williams is great um what else is
there I listen to AR
expert and
M God I feel like there's just so many
like payer weight breakfast all day uh a
lot of audio books on finance I mean I I
do not I I don't want to start listing
off other other react channels fantano
because what ends up happening is I end
up not listing off someone right cuz I I
I know so many of the reaction like the
shadow there's there's been a like these
big group Zoom calls with like a but so
I know so many of them and and I and I
what I hate doing is when I list off
reaction like oh [__] I should have said
that so there's there's a lot of
reaction Channel A lot of them are great
and you guys are Len you guys are
listenting to several of them in the
chat right now and uh I really
appreciate you guys listen them off but
yeah list list off in the chat some
react channels going show them I'm so
love their names will pop up on screen
but I don't want
to the only thing I watch on YouTube is
this Little Indie Channel called hot
ones
watchepisode last night Sterling K Brown
was exceptional enjoy that interview for
people who are tuning in we already
covered the trailers now we're just
doing an open Q&A de eyes uh John you
turn it off I turned them off all right
so let's just make sure all you can send
his stickers now we're make sure we're
on track we're going to refresh I need
to watch some more uh like female
content creators though I feel like I do
you know there's this uh there's this
one movie she she doesn't do reactions
uh she doesn't have a huge channel oh
what is her name her Pops I also have a
PR um Billy binges is great okay I just
shouted Out Billy binges is really funny
I like merse a lot too um let me see
here you guys are just making up words
no merse they're two react channels melv
verse
uhuh a one too is it Mel Gibson or Mel
Brooks Sean Sean
C what is her name she's she is a Roxy
strier no no no no always Lola hear is a
great film always Lola this weekend
Godzilla minus one and always always
back to back double beat support boom do
what is her name she I God damn she's a
great all she she just sits in her
living room she does these reviews and
she and she's such a articulate speaker
like there's this dude I say oh I know
who you're talking about I think Awkward
Ashley is she an Asian woman oh just
name chat nerdy no I mean yeah no there
there is a I don't remember names no
there's a different girl no okay I know
who you're talking about but yeah I'll
watch her too yeah I just kind of see
their thumbs and I go oh yeah yeah let
me watch it but I constantly forget the
names of everyone yeah unless I've been
watching you for years I'm GNA forget
your name all right anyway damn Richie
love lace on Tik Tok eyes do eyes thank
you so much 2023 has been a lot and this
channel makes every day a little
brighter much love to you guys oh thank
you so much you make life a lot rter
thank you thank you SS2 stuck inside
with a cold appreciate y'all a lot I'm
sorry that you have a cold I thought I
was getting sick yesterday I you just
weren't sleeping I started Downing a lot
of vitamins and I feel um I don't feel
sick just a little tired that's but I
feel good there's there's an omn media
shout out in the chat go go give him
some love I'm sorry you feel sick buddy
but thank you for being here hopefully
we can keep you company right now
hopefully we're like chicken soup for
your souls struggle nation's a great
name that's fun fasting struggle Nation
I'm glad you guys like my uh previous
comment about Greg being
W always as it should be lmf hey yo lmow
I know that band laughing my wait
laughing my ass off wasn't sure how it
would be taken seriously though you guys
are amazing I mean thanks out of the
three of us only Ko's the one who can't
take a joke tune in to two weeks ago's
live stream oh that was a good one that
was a little spicy I was leaving all
those comments is do is Doctor Who
already out cuz we're going to get on it
we're going to live react to it here on
on the live stream oh man I love liquid
IV good call Bucky Barnes liquid I drink
one of those every morning and I try to
do a second one every night it's very
expensive hobby but it keeps me
hydrating CU I don't drink enough water
we got a reset for uh mean we we have we
just have to be on track with our
schedule today Deadshot so we're
probably not going to be able to cover
that MK1 trailer alashia Queen that's
her name that's that lady's name that's
the Asian the Asian girl you're talking
about yeah yeah she's great what is that
one girl's name what did she review [__]
what did she talk
about I'll find it later all right all
right fine but no thank you fasty and
yeah we can take a joke most of the time
on camera we can take a joke yeah it's
not a man of the Jedi is it I do watch
am man of the Jedi she's great yeah
she's fun very creative Michael rigs
Michael rigs Fallout TV show should be
Parts Evil Dead idiocracy ex mocking us
space Odyssey and Duke Nukem that is a
kind of a oh my God I love those things
Fallout does feel like a strong
amalgamation of a bunch of different
things and and I guess the question is
is I I feel like understanding what the
unique because it's really easy to look
at a trailer for something that is an
adaptation and go kind of reminds me of
this kind of reminds me of that um but
no Alejandra to answer your question in
the chat right now we haven't played I
mean John's played Fallout Cory and I
haven't played Fallout and looks Wicked
fun and you know the chat kind of goes
back and forth yes Chris swam off
Natalie gold that's her name uh no
Natalie gold is a is is like one of top
movie reactors oh also shouts out
to great one shouts out to De is always
watching de is always watching here um
but the what are we talking about
Fallout uniqueness us not knowing it
yeah I don't really I I I just want to I
kind of want to deep focused lens you
got it yes yes that's who that's who it
was deep focus lens yes she's great
she's like there's not crazy production
goes into her videos but just she could
write a book or some [__] like she's so
good at freaky now like I'll just listen
to her [__] while she's talking I don't
I don't even have to watch the video and
it is she seriously if you want like a
great reviewer deep focused lens she is
excellent excellent reviewer woo um also
great last name absolute vodka way you
AA Aisha Kenya
aishaa happy holidays guys aside from
YouTube what are your personal goals for
2024 is there anything we can do to help
support those goals pulling up my 2024
goals oh my oh my God I thought I
thought Cole was Coy was just checking
out progressively more from this stream
no he's just pulling up his document I
wanna I want Jesus I want to touch 159
lbs I'm currently 168 I want to touch my
toes I've never done that since I was a
baby I want to hit 10% body fat I want
to average 13% body fat I want to take
four trips three East Coast one
international I want to do five cons
minimum I want 150 miles I want to run
do 250 workouts 365 days I want to try
aditt fasting for at least a month I
want to try cold therapy for at least a
month I want to try cardio Focus for a
month I want to try no process foods
month I want to experience 12 new
restaurants at least one a month I want
to experience one new country minimum
next month I want to experience one new
thing for my job I want to get 250,000
across social media I want to do an 8
minute mile I want to do a 26.2 mile
distance want to do a marathon basically
225 on my bench again more regularly 100
100 curl regularly one push-up per squat
per day of that year are my goals next
year I'm G get them I got 24 goals for
2024 I didn't read my four financial
goals because that's personal but you
got 20 I did read um that is um
no that's amazing that's what I want
those are 20 of my 2024 goals I got 24
of them I didn't read the finance ones
the person got something against my
goals Greg got something against my
goals I read your Finance
goals that's some really impressive you
guys just break it down into increments
so yeah there's four there there's
different there's four I think you have
enough goals for all three of us no look
it's it's sections of four and they're
all different styles of goal I think
important need organize my goals the way
you do uh my goals are um they're script
related and uh they're already on track
for something awesome and I got a couple
emails about it um just this week dude
congratulations it's great way to start
next year momentum the way to get to do
next year you start now a lot of people
wait till till January but you start now
like I'm always about getting had it's
always next year I wrote those out
December 1st like that is uh that's what
I do and I and I started my 2024
calendar yesterday uh I scroll the wrong
way let's just read the skip follow TV
show should be Parts Evil Dead ocracy ex
space let go back is John is there
another movie you would include onto
this list uh cuz I said Westworld part
of it versus Aliens I said
Westworld little bit of Mad Max uh I
haven't seen the Creator but I'm going
to say the Creator I haven't seen the
Creator either
but the Creator kind of yeah sort of
yeah contribute if the Creator was set
in a desert rather than all of East Asia
say something to
this um um haven't seen Idiocracy oh
what oh damn dog Ian what's part Evil
Dead I didn't get Evil Dead I mean other
than the guess Goin looks like kind I
guess there there's a bit of zann in
there there's a little sprinkling of
I'll think of more uh uh uh influences
here metad Del taera saying right here
we guys sup guys love your content saw
koi and KK kville a few weeks ago and
wanted to say hi but you had company oh
K Town my bad I misread it yeah yeah I
thought oh I I heard about in L should
be
confused there miss my chance but
hopefully another time dude oh my God if
if you recognize Coy he would love that
so please go say hi to your face be like
as long as it's attention big lior Coy
is going to be happy to see in the
bathroom so many people try to say hi in
the bathroom and it's never like there's
no way to handle it there's no polite
way to be like hold on let's just leave
this
bathroom that's how you claim I just
move it over and then I go now you'll
remember me yeah you just turn directly
to face them peeing
yeah dude you got to do an idiocracy
unless I'm eating or peeing say hi guys
look at the the three women who are
always in the chat here beautiful
beautiful appreciate you also Michelle
watches my channel which makes me so
happy thank you Michelle trying to grow
it got almost 22,000 guys she watches
your channel sorry Michelle it's time to
now we got to ban you sorry about that
that s only one of us at a time where's
your Allegiance I love I love Korea Town
and as long as I'm not eating or peeing
please say hi
Dakota Jones Dakota again another one I
love seeing the familiar faces it's like
a sophomore season of any show uh saying
is Marie gonna give homelander brain
bleeding do you Coy do you think do you
think Marie is GNA show up in boy season
4 uh I think briefly I think they'll be
setting up where basically genv season 2
goes throughout the boys so I think
there's going to be like a not even a b
plot but like a C or D plot with some of
those characters but I think it'd be a
little distracting I liked how gen V
didn't have too much of the boys in it I
think likewise if you make homelander
too related to gen V it'll kind of um
Sully both shows so I don't think
they'll be directly related but I think
it'll be like a CD plot hell I love CD
plots compact disc plot I've never seen
Children of Men Louis Santos uh we
appreciate the Super Chat immensely we
did say earlier in the Stream though
that we are going to be avoiding the
Jack Reacher trailer yes and I know it
sounds silly but we're we're going to
watch it in just a couple of weeks uh
they're premiering three episodes and
I'm just like well we already didn't see
the first trailer so we might as well
just go and like we don't know what's
going to happen let's see we're already
hyped it's going to come out in a few
weeks and then and the less we know I
think the better of an experience it'll
be because we we have enough time to
forget about what we saw in this house
of the Dragon trailer yes it was very V
we have enough time to forget about what
we saw in this Boys trailer cuz that
that's usually what happens for for us
we watch a trailer this early in advance
is that I will completely forget at
least on mine I'll be like I don't
remember at all what happened uh all
righty cool thanks Jason thank you Louis
Santos thanks for watching the the first
Blood video appreciate that I loved that
that was great a nice surprise excited
for second blood yeah it's really cool
that you guys were able to pretend that
you hadn't seen First Blood com really
hard so many of the comments are so
funny like they've obviously seen this
and I was like we get stuff wrong that
that become my favorite comment is like
half the movies we do now people get in
there and they're like no there's just
no way you didn't see this this such a
weird activity to do there's a reason
why uh there's a bigger variety of
people who come on the channel now
because we've seen of course like I've
most of us have like I literally have to
come up with like a giant list of movies
based off recommendations or a variety
of other things yeah and then it becomes
like email blast and then trying sort
out and then seeing like there's like a
whole checklist and the whole
questionnaire comes back to like tell me
which ones you have seen and which ones
you haven't seen then it becomes about a
signing there's this whole process that
is very intricate to make sure but
there's always someone to be like oh
they haven't seen that be like they've
totally seen it when there's there's an
entire process to make John hasn't
watched like five of my top 20 movies MJ
I have not seen Saturday Night Fever I
don't know if quite has I've not either
dude John hasn't seen Fight Club
Diego first time making it to a stream
watching your videos throughout the
years have helped me get through when
times were tough so thank you yeah
whatever moving
on from the grave interesting thank you
so much Diego you know it's kind of
crazy that we have been doing this for
several years all this time it doesn't
feel like several years and yet it
somehow does that's how time works I'm
still in the same Panic oh my God
survive mode no matter how long we've
been doing this Panic is here Tera just
yesterday was like How come every time I
come over it's oh my God there's an
emergency I don't got time to talk we
got to get to this Hurry Up This is your
Perpetual existence that's how we all
arrived that is I'm sorry I'm so sorry
Terra that's the doorway come through
that doorway you're coming into that for
Tera you're going to change that but not
for any of the rest no we have to live
it um let
me uh I've seen prisoners JN and I saw
pris in theaters that was one of the
first movies you ever reviewed it's my
favorite Jake Gyllenhaal
Michelle you haven't seen prison no I
love prisoners my fav it's Michelle
supporter of the koi jro YouTube channel
Michelle that Super Chat is just for Koy
love you Michelle you're always up here
uh Charlie 836 any update on Arcane
season 2 we got the download for you
guys we've been working hard on it all
right and production is going great Greg
has been drawing all the animation Coy's
been writing the scripts and I've been
doing the voiceover this season it stick
figures definitely we just figured we
can get the show done faster you care
more about the writing then you do the
anime figures they don't have to move
even they just stand there and we do let
the dialog talk a me flipping a book yep
all my dialogue involves the CW I hope
you're
ready there it
is Char 836 Spidey Sensei 72 this is
Roxy strier ghost account
yes Ron Joy yo Char 836 I love your your
profile pick man that is so sexy yeah
buddy um Spidey Sensei 72 just a
reminder go watch always Lola and help
support Roxy's new movie this weekend it
so you know what I saw on this was crazy
100% Rond is it de yeah yeah yeah and
guys um I bought the movie already Yes
and um the we we were we were looking up
we John and I watched
eza and we were looking up reviews on
while we were reviewing it and then on
the most popular section like I said for
most popular on ronto Manas and I don't
think it's like specifically algorithm
generated like I I'm pretty sure it's
like what is currently just really
popular right now always Lola was was
there I was like damn that's nuts oh
that's so exciting good for her man nuts
beautiful go Roxy I got well deserved
fake account and talk [__] about her
yeah one star I'm like if we bring her
down then that will make her commitment
here last long'll strength her she feels
like she needs to fill the void with
reaction starts getting more acting work
and she can't be here as much so if I
talk [__] about her yeah humble her make
her look make make make casting
directors think that people don't like
her that way she's not on the I started
a bunch of dummy accounts like to
pretend to be casting directors
commenting on the video what I've
learned about leading the channel is you
got to tear people down right down in
order to keep them around it's like a
horse you just reel it in let them go
you reel them back in the movie
always Lola is streaming right now there
may be some screenings around if you
it's video on demand so you got to rent
or purchase it so uh yeah
Diego Diego Diego sorry Ike it's off
topic but have you three ever consider
reacting to Young Justice or Harley
Quinn would love to hear your thoughts
on those interpretations of the
characters top tier shows uh young
justice has sometimes come up in the
conversation committing to a show that
is not performing well really [__] you
in the algorithm not going to lie in the
like rebounding from Scott it's it's
what sucks is a lot of times it's just
show we love like rebounding from Scott
Pilgrim sad John and I did not love
Witcher season 3 at all and no that was
one of the most disheartening
experiences when you're like we're not
even liking this show we're committed to
finishing it and it's getting shitty ass
views at the same time so I would much
rather be watching a certain other show
we will not algorithm and then Scott Von
versus the world I mean takes off that
was a bummer because it didn't do well
but on on the channel however we really
love this show and it is one of those
disheartening effects when you're like
man but whenever we upload we know it's
affecting us in the algorithm and now we
got to bounce back it's drowning other
things a weird thing so that's the
that's the scarier part about committing
to a show because it's got to be it's
got to be good you got to be like we got
to lot we got to know we're very
interested in it even if we don't like
it we got to know we are at least very
interested in watching it m because
that's what that's what really matters
and and then and secondly hopefully does
well yeah [__] it's it's like a movie
might not do well but it's a movie two
hours and you're like and it has a
different chance of growing yeah whereas
a show has a very limited shelf life
Santiago heck Mt is also good shouts out
to master tainment Mt is a g I love his
work on heavy spoilers a lot I think
he's amazing great um
uh yeah okay sorry to answer the
question um I've seen the first two
seasons of of Harley Quinn I've seen the
first three there's a fourth coming out
now or the fourth greit have you seen
any Harley seen z% of Harley Quin great
so good I've heard I haven't seen the
the Valentine's Day special though oh I
yeah behind on Harley Quinn but no it's
a John it's so good it's it's like what
tone you want from an R-rated cartoon
comedy yeah yeah all right I'm excited
one of these days it's like like birds
of prey but Everyone likes this one
instead yeah we like our women two
dimensional and the kit I love birds of
prey I love birds of pre it's in my top
five VC and Michelle I appreciate that
you loved the Scott Pilgrim coverage it
was all for you it was all for you
Michelle oh my god did we reach the top
did we reach it okay cuz yeah what time
is it we got a all right yeah yeah yeah
sweet I'm always into something all
right cool we did it gu let me just make
sure we got everything here we'll do a
couple quick sound offs then we're do it
we'll get to rock and yeah we're caught
up we've done it sweet sauce John
removes this thing and then we talk to
people all right be rid of the thing are
these trailers coming out La ComiCon uh
no they're coming out of Brazil yeah
Brazil ComicCon which is why we are
covering a Brazilian film which is why
none of us are at La comic sometimes I
put out on the list of movies I put out
a foreign film on there and I'm like I
know every everyone's going to tell me
they haven't seen it cuz they all city
of God no not city city of God is a
Brazilian film actually I thought that
was the reference I haven't se now would
have been the time to do City that's
been on the list for months I have not
seen it I'll put you and Aaron on there
cool I for not obvious reasons I like
Aaron uh nope this is just going to be a
stream it's get two white dudes watching
the Brazilian movie hey uh let's uh so
guys uh thank you so much for being here
uh we got to set up and get re quainted
we have I mean all three I think all
three of us have seen children men I
have not seen children of men that was
the main talking point in my Creator
review is I reference children of it's
been on my list forever I've mentioned
this multiple times he hasn't seen Fight
Club that's going to vex me until he SE
seen Children of Men I want to watch
Fight Club with you and I'll be my 17th
time reaction to your first time reac
you know what you should do whoever we
should I'll pair up with somebody to
react but we'll have you sitting just
facing me just watching you watch Fight
Club yeah I want my favorite movie of
all time we we'll put you in the corner
in a separate box seems like for a solo
John video the ones that do the best are
if they're like an animated movie sure
that's fine yeah I mean I'm nothing has
to happen I'm just saying I've not seen
children of mint and I would love to see
animated children of soon anyway guys
look we got to end this stream but thank
you guys so much uh you made this
experience way more enjoyable so I'm so
sorry pet have you seen Peter Griffin is
in fortnite that's hilarious it was one
of those uh disgusting film posts where
you see it and it just said uh fortnite
is is putting Peter Griffin in the game
it releases December 5th and everyone
has been meming it because it's one of
those where you're like this is disusing
no it's just the regular disgusting film
so people have been putting all sorts of
other meme characters in so I'm happy
that's taken uh random I've read every
Chuck pic book but is most recent too
big Chuck pic fan I've read Fight Club
many times and I've read books about
Fight Club like philosophical studies
and stuff that's amazing fought in a
club I am putting uh kash's ending this
I got to end this guys I got to end it
but
so thank you Jason and fasty for keeping
us on track love you guys uh yeah we got
a lot coming out this week keep a look
out tomorrow will not be a live stream
for Godzilla vers konggo will just be a
regular trailer reaction uh but I'm
excited for it Charlie 836 Joe the man
Michelle every there's a lot of people
who come thank you for
the I want to shout out
Chris again for massive generous Super
Chat and uh I want to get the right name
St sorry I want to get your name right
shout out the big one where's that every
everyone who contributed thank you
because yeah this stream got demonetized
immediately instantly so thank you guys
and stupid sandwich thank you so much
for another very generous Super Chat um
but yeah guys uh this is over that's it
unless there's anything else we should
play nope no no no that it should have
been mid all right Bucky thanks for
holding it down see you guys John close
us out I've been holding in bathroom for
30 minutes he's got a pie he's leaving